good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
are you really coming to Melbourne
Australia yes there will be an awesome
nerdfighter gathering beginning at 2:00
p.m. in Melbourne on may 31st to promote
this the Australian edition of my new
book Paper Towns if you want to come and
I sincerely hope you do you can book
your spot and find out more information
in the sidebar what is a nerdfighter
Hank sometimes it's like people haven't
devoted the 24 hours necessary to watch
all 465 of our videos nerdfighters are
just like regular people except instead
of being made out of bones and tissues
and organs and etc they're made out of
Awesome is there some kind of initiation
process for joining nerdfighters oh just
a small one you have to ride a puppy
sized elephant around the circumference
of winter South Dakota while holding an
abundance of katherines in your pants on
your head all of those jokes and more
will make sense if you just watch all of
our videos but seriously if you want to
be a nerdfighter you are one so is this
just like communication between two guys
and then people were interested so they
subscribed it is in fact just like that
yes what is dftba mean dinosaurs failed
to beat asteroid who is your worst
girlfriend probably the one who kissed
like a lion the first time we kissed I
was all like and she was like class and
then I was like ow my face you aided it
what is the meaning of life mostly
listening some jokes why did the
brilliant always die young actually the
brilliant died at all ages fine fine was
76 but we romanticized the young ones
what's your favorite poem all my
favorite poems are too long to recite in
a question Tuesday video except for the
last poem John Keats ever wrote which
was also his last will and testament one
line of perfect iambic pentameter my
chest of books divided amongst my
friends why do guys get obsessed to the
point of creepy stalker ism well they
could really fixated on the idea that
your affection is what stands between
them and happiness but the thing is that
no single person ever stands between you
and happiness and fixation is not the
same thing as love is your puffs and
homage to Edward Cullen no you don't
choose the puff the puff chooses you is
your puff up to date on it shots ha ha
ha is your joke up to date on its
funniness mom they made a hair joke that
hurt my feelings how do I get Maureen
Johnson
to like me well you can either buy your
new book sweet scarlet which is
brilliant
comes out in paperback in a few short
days or you can become a puppy Willy
green consistently baffled by the puppy
in the mirror wait your book Paper Towns
is being turned into a movie yeah maybe
the people who made Juno option the
rights to it with me writing the
screenplay so I'm working on that now
how many of your exes are named
Katherine zero is heck gonna make a
second CD I hope so but in the meantime
why don't you buy this first CD link in
the sidebar in fact if you buy it in the
next week I will email you a special
secret bonus video why you talk so fast
too many words too little time what does
it take for me to get my question on
question Tuesday perseverance and
brevity what language do peeps speak
beep is it possible to die of peat
poisoning according to my physician yes
what if the peeps rise up in revolt as a
result of the peat genocide caused by
nerdfighters that is in fact exactly how
my doctor told me that peeps could kill
me are you wearing pants you mean am i
wearing pants of course I'm wearing
pants did jammy pants count what
happened your superpower nerd glasses um
it's kind of a long story but it ends
with me falling face-first into the
Baltic Sea and breaking them if the
internet exploded one of the projects
would you like to work on well the first
project I would work on would be called
fixing the internet hold on who the eff
is Hank Hank is a breed of dog known for
its distinctive white coat hank was
originally bred to dig out foxholes but
these days hank is known primarily for
being adorable
licky and for urinating in inappropriate
places did I just see a Westie no you
just saw a Hank why don't you blink well
if you've been watching Brotherhood 2.0
from the beginning you know that in
March of 2007 I had to go to the
hospital for an eye infection as a
result of that infection they installed
robot eyes do you still need more
questions yes please leave them in
comments Hank I'll see you singing
tomorrow